we recently went on a vacation and we
completely unplugged everything it was
kind of amazing because you guys take
cool vacations where did you go
we went to Big Sur which is kind of you
know a lot of nature Big Sur we get the
whole audience everyone who's at Big Sur
there's a bus that picks up our audience
at Big Sur and drives him down the coast
it's very allowed five-hour drive yeah
so we went and we were so tired at
Thanksgiving and we literally checked
our cell phones at the front desk of the
hotel and didn't have cell phones for 10
days didn't have any electronics and it
was amazing there was no you know like
separation anxiety or anything like that
we just immediately started doing like
500 jigsaw puzzles and reading books and
I kind of got to know him all over again
I learned his middle name is really
coming in gray he didn't realize my hair
had gotten longer yeah you're supposed
to realize how much you love each other
not things like you have a middle name
oh you're Protestant you got less room
for this now whoa look at ya now is it
one of those rustic places I've been to
some places that there's literally like
you go use an outhouse is it one of
those deals
uh no it's extremely fancy however Conan
I think I would do well and Andy I think
I would do well in a rustic setting
because one of my special skills that
really not very many people know about
is that I enjoy peeing outside you're
very good at it I'm I considered myself
to be quite good at okay and like okay
all right I recently went to the next
level
well in the spirit of holidays let's
hear about that okay you might be
thinking something else but the next
level the the natural obvious next level
is peeing into a bottle in a moving
vehicle oh and they're not moving in a
vehicle so yeah that was not what I was
thinking is the next level in no I
wanted to challenge myself we were we
were stalled out on the highway summer
between North and South Carolina on our
comedy tour because we drive ourselves
we rent an SUV a drive so we're in this
car and we are at a complete standstill
for two hours behind an accident
involving a logging truck if you must
know and the restroom and I couldn't get
out of the car because everybody's at a
full stop and there's headlights and
people are probably wandering around you
can't go out there yeah yeah there's a
lot of stuff happening so um Nick cut
off the top of a plastic bottle and I
crawled over the front seat into the
back seat and it was crammed with all of
our luggage and our dog crate and our
guitar cases and you know all these
things so I get in there I'm in a little
space it's just like this bag and I have
my little bottle and I did it and and I
did a girl
and the bottle almost wasn't big enough
cuz I really had to go yeah
and then Nick just like it was like a
medical show he just opened the door of
the car and he just poured it out onto
the highway that's what they did you
know got sure love that is a true loving
couple were you work with that kind of
synchronicity that's beautiful
you